et là là on va beaucoup moins rire parce
que si vous vous aimez cristina Cordula
on va essayer de continuer de l'aimer
mais là on a découvert quelque chose le
mode le monde de la mode incroyable en
plus de Rennes du shopping cristina
Cordula la star de la mode de M6 travail
sur le rôle hooking et en privé et elle
seule c'est un véritable phénomène
regardez ce qu'elle fait et qu'on met à
gagne par jour pour relooker sur des
gens des gens qui en ont besoin
[Musique]
vous la connaissez pour ces expressions
légendaires c'est magnifique ma chérie
pour ton Instagram du shopping pour une
nouvelle vie depuis près de 20 ans
cristina Cordula il a caution mode d'M6
allô ma chérie excuse-moi j'ai du goût
des lois des caméras la charmante
brésilienne est une vraie business woman
maquillage pour la colorimétrie la
morphologie shopping sur son site
cristina Cordula propose différentes
formations de conseils en morphologie et
loupe de colorimétrie ou de conseils en
images mais l'animatrice de M6 n'est pas
la seule à profiter de sa visibilité et
de sa notoriété pour développer son
business de nombreux politiciens font
part de leur expertise aussi en vendant
des conférences François Hollande
facturerait entre 30 000 45000 euros ses
conseils alors que Nicolas Sarkozy
pourrait prendre jusqu'à 200000 euros la
prestation travailler plus pour gagner
plus et il n'y a pas que les politiques
qui proposent ce genre de service
Philippe Etchebest propose du coaching
en cuisine mais t'as vu ce champ de ton
frérot quand même tu vois empoisonner
des gens ou quoi tandis que l'actuel
entraîneur de l'équipe de France de
rugby Fabien Galtier propose des
ateliers de gestion d'équipe de rugby
c'est un cercle à l'intérieur vous avez
des talents des prestations qui peuvent
aller parfois jusqu'à 10000 euros bref
si vous souhaitez suivre une formation
pour devenir animateur il ne vous reste
plus qu'à contacter Mathieu Delormeau
[Musique]
voilà choqué pas choqué juste une phrase
cristina Cordula en une journée peut
empocher jusqu'à
83750 euros
25 personnes sur 3 jours et elle les
reloue qu'elle se fait 85000 balles
êtes-vous choqué pas choqué est-ce que
ça les vaut les réponses dans un instant
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nouveau tube hymne dans un temps fera
un énorme débat avec les anciens
nastarac il va donner plein de petites
infos totalement exclusives sur ce que
ce qui va se passer dans la Star Ac très
bientôt pour l'instant on était sur
potin de stars 3000 euros pour un
relooking de Cristina Cordula ça vous
prend trois jours en fait et en trois
jours de prendre 1000 euros par jour
normalement à la fin des trois jours
vous êtes beaux vous étiez moche vous
êtes beaux et le problème c'est que
forcément il y a beaucoup de demandes
grâce à M6 parfois elle prend jusqu'à 25
personnes en même temps donc ce qui fait
en fait 25 faut grosso modo 3350 euros
on va dire TTC ça nous fait du 83750
euros les trois jours pour vous relooker
alors choquer pas choquer il y a quand
même pas mal c'est OK et regarde-moi
j'ai un petit peu de correct on sent que
tu as un CDI RTL
me touche mais je vois ce que touche les
Obama ce que touche sarkoz que tout
touche pour faire des prestations si
vous avez pas envie d'y aller vous y
allez pas c'est pas une arnaque
normalement alors moi j'ai un avis mais
je le donne pas je suis animateur moi ce
qui me gêne c'est par rapport à la cible
elle s'adresse à la ménagère aux jeunes
sur M6 à 16h avec les reines du shopping
ceux qui ont envie d'avoir des conseils
de Cristina Cordula ne peuvent pas
mettre les 3000 €, c'est des gens qui
vont volontairement
que tous ces fans à 16h qui la regardent
dans les reines du shopping ont
peut-être envie d'avoir des conseils de
Cristina Cordula pourquoi toujours
offrir à une classe sociale
de ta sœur la fin c'est ça c'est des
missions avec Nicolas weldor incroyable
transformation aussi et c'est vrai que
ta sœur qui est très jolie mais elle
aurait jamais les moyens de mettre 3000
balles pour un relooking
mais quand tu regardes Christina c'est
pas non plus
aucun regret c'est pas faux alors
attends Magali quand même qui est une
femme et puis Florian parce que j'ai un
doute
des choses en place c'est que c'est sous
facturation dessus elle paye des charges
tout le monde croit qu'elle se les mets
dans la poche mais déjà tu enlèves la
moitié qui paye les charges c'est pas
grave
faut le dire faut arrêter de penser que
les gens touchent ça dans leur poche que
c'est nette dans la poche
premièrement ensuite je suis désolé
Mathieu tu t'adresses aussi à la
ménagère aujourd'hui de payer combien
pour faire une heure de travail là pour
présenter une émission
[Applaudissements]
Mathieu mais son talent si si il y en a
voilà
de la chaîne mais elle elle met son
talent au service des gens qui ont envie
d'avoir des
couches
je réagis parce que tu dis elle elle met
son talent bah non parce que quand tu
regardes la petite formation il y a
qu'un tiers de la formation qui se passe
avec elle en plus
il y a au moins 8 heures avec le reste
de ses équipes était 25 pelos comme ça
oui non mais d'accord mais pas que elle
et voilà et quand tu regardes moi j'ai
décrypté son site il y a un nombre de
formations c'est délirant je veux dire
il y a un nombre de trucs différents
pour que finalement elle puisse bouffer
à tous les râteliers sur ce créneau là
je l'ai appelé moi j'ai ici j'ai voulu
en parler avec elle je lui ai proposé
pour lui poser des petites questions si
elle m'a répondu mais elle a été odieuse
alors c'est des questions très simples
j'ai voulu échanger avec elle sur la
question n'a pas été très sympa et je
trouve que sa réaction n'était pas la
réaction de quelqu'un qui n'a qui ont
quelque chose mais si tu attends c'est
clair il faut retenir alors sur Florian
c'est qu'en plus il y a des gens qu'elle
a certainement embauché dont elle paye
en plus sur sa prestation tu peux
retenir ça aussi mais oui du coup c'est
des gens aussi qu'elle embauche
il y a beaucoup d'abus sur beaucoup de
gens moi ce qui me choque un tout petit
peu mieux comme un petit peu c'est que
malgré tout quand tu fais ça c'est que
tu t'adresses à des gens qui entre
guillemets sont pas très bien dans leur
basket tu vois ce que je veux dire que
tu te sens moche et tout ça donc tu
t'adresses un petit peu facile voilà je
donne alors Laurent Natacha pas du tout
parce que là encore pas de démagogie ce
que les gens savent pas forcément c'est
que la plupart des gens qui font nos
métiers qui font la télé ont des
activités payées en plus parce que quand
tu fais de la télé ton image vaut de
l'argent et que tu fais par exemple et
vous êtes nombreux à l'avoir déjà fait
des boîtes de nuit qu'est-ce qui fait
que tu vas te retrouver à à
Chalon-sur-Saône dans une boîte de nuit
on va combat en sortie de ville le prix
de la boîte de nuit change pas moi quand
je fais des boîtes de nuit près de la
bonne nuit je change pas pour des gens
c'est que tu prends de l'argent pour une
prestation en dehors bah oui c'est pas
exactement soyons pas hypocrite là
encore et certainement que tu dirais une
somme que tu prends pour aller passer
deux heures une boîte de nuit ça
chaufferait tous les gens qui sont
pas en cause directement plein de gens
le font très bien faisons de tour de
tableaux et très honnête Jean-Mi tu as
déjà fait les prestations boîte de nuit
avec toi
[Rires]
pourquoi personne ne respecte merde j'ai
l'animateur autant de faire chier jamais
comment tu prenais
environ entre 2000 et 3000 €. d'accord
pour 2h de boîte de nuit pour deux
heures et moi je calculais pas mon temps
donc je restais jusqu'à la fin d'accord
justement de son métier maintenant tu
faisais quoi moi des booking déménages
ouais alors moi quand j'étais vraiment
au top ça c'était dégradé mais j'étais à
4000 euros
pour faire un booking mais c'est pas les
gens qui me plaisent c'est le patron de
la boîte demandez pas on se rend compte
que c'est alors il faut quand même dire
aux gens peut-être la vérité aussi parce
qu'un jour j'ai un pote qui m'a dit tu
fais ça pour deux heures c'est vrai que
c'est les tarifs comprenaient à peu près
3 4000 €, je dis la vérité mais c'est
vrai que non c'est pas pour deux heures
tu prends le train tu as 3 heures de
train tu arrives là-bas
ils sont pas fort mais c'est pas tu
dînes avec le patron de la boîte tu dors
tu dors dans l'hôtel là-bas au mercure
tu reparles